[Musica]
da qualche mese fa è successa una cosa
praticamente mi risveglio e su twitter
sono pieno zeppo di notifiche mastra
como e vedo molti screenshot di una
pagina facebook di un hamburgeria con la
mia facciona stampata su uno dei loro
post che dico io non credo di aver mai
fatto
non ho mai sponsorizzato niente sul
canale principale tantomeno un
hamburgeria lombarda io non sono sicuro
al cento per cento non l'ho mai fatta in
queste cose qui non ne ho mai fatte
quelle cose che volevo quindi vado a
controllare vado sulla pagina facebook
di questa bottiglia
vado a cercare imposto e noto che sul
post loro hanno preso il mio video epico
epicor non so se vi ricordate che
l'hanno usato come spot pubblicitario
quella nuova hamburgeria ecco a voi
avete mai visto il poco ecco imposta che
ci sono su facebook dove c'è claudio
lippi
ve lo ricordate claudio lippi lo che
dicono che è diventato milionario come
gli investimenti in qualche banche
quelle pubblicità fasulli stime del
povero claudio coletta
a circa un lippi ma che non è vero
niente no è il problema di quei posti no
il problema di utilizzare l'immagine di
qualcun altro per sponsorizzare la tua
hamburgeria e che poi la gente non è
tanto il posto anzi io sono molto
contento anzi i proprietari della murga
io li ho anche contattato gli ho scritto
guardate potete togliere il posto la mia
immagine dal vostro posto e gentili sì
ha detto certamente lo togliamo io ho
detto grazie mille bombe romy il
problema non è imposto la gente che non
capisce che io con quel posto a produrlo
è capito quel post anche la nonna
infatti scrive delle cose che a me non
piacciono morto dice adesso fa le
pubblicità come tutti norme no io con
quelle pubblicità lino fasulle che non
solo viene per docente avete capito la
dovete smettere di utilizzare l'immagine
pubblica dei di personaggi pubblici per
fare pubblicità alle cose
i membri le cui questi cazzo di sposo o
fasulli non è tanto il fatto che io sia
contento ma è che la gente non capisce
io non c'entro nulla con quelle cose lì
capito e poi l'appello per nessun motivo
io stavo sdraiato sul divano e poi mi
ritrovo a essere testimonia di una roba
che non sapeva
avete capito è quello un problema
machine tranquillo io la prendo
teneramente si erano tranquillamente io
è a posto
comunque tutto qui volevo soltanto di
dire questa cosa qua e grazie